neptr boy sir this is the master control
I have a truck of interest in the system
for you Zulu Zulu zero zero one piece
East Coast heading at Northwest line now
I'm 35,000 feet yeah I can see it on
your radar Roger that's understood
according to the operations and qra this
is the black dog master controller
acknowledge your 8q on for quick
reaction alert scramble scramble
scramble Devon it sure
[Applause]
grumble to the story to intercept this
contract
wonderful
and then Steve initially digital at nine
petition interrogated
[Music]
they'll be giving us instructions and as
more information is fed to them and they
gave more information from other sources
and then gradually there's an escalation
process if that needs to occur there's
nothing new in there that we don't
practice and training just picks in and
the adrenaline
nine types of accepting aircraft you to
kind of simplify the budget each
shipment of the night biggest award you
but if you did not respond to PG&E to my
order sincerity you will be shut down